حسنًا، أولاً، إيغور قبل أن أجيب على
السؤال، أريد فقط أن أقول إنه بينما
تقف في الخطوط الأمامية الليلة،
فإنك تدافع عن حرية
بلدك ولكن كما قال الرئيس بايدن في
وارسو قبل ليلتين، أنت صديقك الذي
تدافع عن الحرية في كل مكان.  ولذا
أريد أن أقول شكراً
لشجاعتك وشجاعتك وللرجال
والنساء الذين يقاتلون معك،
نحن ممتنون لكل ما
تقدمونه من تضحيات
ولا يمكننا حتى أن نبدأ في تخيل
الصعوبات و  التجارب التي
مررت بها ما يمكننا القيام به هو
كل ما في وسعنا لتزويدك
بالمعدات والذخيرة التي
تحتاجها وقد ذكرت
155 قذيفة مدفعية ملم وقذائف
دبابة 120 ملم وأنظمة أخرى
مثل صواريخ High Mars التي أنت
أيضًا  لقد ناقشنا للتو أحد الأشياء
التي نعمل بجد عليها بناءً على
توجيهات الرئيس بايدن وهو زيادة إنتاج
كل هذه الأنواع من الذخيرة هنا
في الولايات المتحدة ولكن أيضًا في
دول الناتو بحيث يكون إجمالي المعروض من
كل من هذه الأشكال المختلفة من الذخيرة
الذخيرة تتزايد شهرا بعد شهر
ويمكننا مواصلة التحرك إلى الخطوط الأمامية
أه هذه الذخيرة والكميات
اللازمة لكي تتمكنوا من
القيام بدفاع ناجح ولكي
تتمكنوا من استعادة الأراضي التي
احتلتها روسيا
هذا ليس شيئًا يمكننا القيام به بطرفة
إصبع، ولكنه شيء
نبذل فيه جهدًا وموارد هائلة، ويقوم
وزير الدفاع
لويد أوستن كل شهر بجمع 50
دولة معًا في أوروبا من أجل
تقييم التقدم الذي أحرزناه وكل شهرين.  بعد
أسابيع، سمح الرئيس بايدن بإرسال
حزمة جديدة من الذخيرة إلى أوكرانيا،
ونحن نحاول زيادة أعدادها
بأسرع ما يمكن
لأننا ندرك أن ذلك أمر
أساسي لنجاحكم في القتال، لذا
سنواصل القيام بذلك  كل ما يمكننا
القيام به بشأن هذه القضية المحددة للغاية هو أن الأمر
لا يتعلق فقط بالخطابات أو الكلمات، بل
يتعلق بتسليم البضائع فعليًا،
وهذا ما نحاول القيام به